you know i always think about the the
funniest thing about
my brother dying and not that it's funny
but the funniest thing
is the [ __ ] people that reach out to
you and try to like
comfort you and they don't necessarily
you know people don't know how to
comfort
another person when they're dead no so
people would send me pictures
of my brother photoshopped in the clouds
oh my god
like a skating rink and it was like the
most brilliant
[ __ ] like like a hoodie hey that
here's this one that's more of
the one of him in the clouds he looked
like a ghetto astronaut bruh it was so
[ __ ] up
the most ghetto [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my [ __ ]
life i can't get enough of them so
raggedy i was like how's it supposed to
help me i love [ __ ]
it's a
you'll see what you'll see with like
nipsey with like gypsy there's so many
they had wings on there were so many
like wings spray painted shirts
like print shelf i know i know dude it
was
like that was picking him in the clouds
oh my gosh that's the [ __ ] i kept
getting i was like
because photoshop was like you know
really popping people everybody was
getting it
everybody thought they had photoshop
skills they thought they were so they
were they thought they were helping me
out i was like brother son
[ __ ] help me hate that [ __ ] dude man
this is ridiculous
that's like my prom in louisiana was so
a
catholic priest got arrested along with
two other women
for having sex at the church altar
because somebody walking past
by saw two women starting to have sex
and then they reported it to the police
they kept watching saw that the father
came in and then started having sex with
them they were recording
and the only reason why they got
arrested is because it was in view of
the public not because they were [ __ ]
oh damn look at that [ __ ] look at
this yeah you think he wasn't gonna do
that
by the way how did he convince these two
girls to do it first of all
those two girls convinced them because
one of them is a dominatrix and then the
other one i think she
is also a sex worker i don't know what
type refresh my memory what's a
dominatrix
um like double clamps like leather like
oh yes
yes you're like the girl who does this
you know what's weird is one's 23 wants
41. tell me which one i have no idea
yeah i couldn't figure it out all in the
eyebrows
but i can tell you
yeah look at her style
she she knows herself she's a little bit
more cleaned up a 23 year old would look
like that
this could be a scary movie skit yeah
homie
he looks terrible and i think catholic
priests aren't like supposed to have any
i don't even think they're allowed to be
married right yeah they're celibate
yeah yeah that's a lot he did [ __ ]
awesome
look at that guy come on dude yeah of
course he's gonna do who's going to
church and be like oh yeah he seems like
a good
[ __ ] come on
oh yeah there's a tour a canadian
tourist who uh went to pompeii when she
was like
21 years old she wanted a piece of
history from there
that she said she couldn't like you
couldn't buy and so she stole different
artifacts
from the land she says that she's
certain she was cursed for 15 years she
had breast cancer twice
had a double mastectomy she ended up
actually sending those things back to
the museum in pompei and
basically apologizing saying that she
didn't know
what taking those artifacts would entail
and she didn't she doesn't want the bad
luck anymore she doesn't want to pass it
on
to her kids and so she's trying to
return it hoping that her luck
goes back to normal she goes she goes
the the last time ending a double
mastectomy my family i also suffered
financial problems we're good people and
i don't want to pass this curse along to
my family or children
and the head of the museum says that a
lot of people do that where they take
[ __ ]
and then they end up mailing it back
because they have so much bad luck like
it's not uh
well you're just not supposed to steal
yeah [ __ ] she goes we took them
uh we got money at the time we need to
be
different this [ __ ] took something from
the
the the victims of the pompeii i don't
steal from the museum
i had a horrible death and fire and i
saw them
hell no it wasn't good we took them out
thinking of the pain suffering these
poor souls experienced during the
eruption of
uh that in a terrible death wow wow
over the years so many stolen relics
have been returned to the site along
with
expressing guilt wow well just don't do
that
well you don't know what people are
going through i stole uh
well you didn't steal well i don't have
enough i don't have enough money go to
pope
pompey yeah
well i wouldn't have to steal if my
queen if she can fly me i can buy that
no she could buy it for you okay i don't
think you can buy this stuff though
that's not you sure
you sure you can't buy artifacts from
i don't think so we can probably have a
gift shop first of all stop being an
[ __ ] and taking that why do you need
that let it be where it is
yeah why do you need that she learned
the hard way she said she wanted a piece
of history that you couldn't buy
they took something from hawaiian secret
place and then they were like cursed as
well
i've been uh by the brady bunch house
multiple times where's that
studio city there's a yeah there's
security there uh the whole time
oh really yeah but didn't they i went
for sale recently i think no it did not
really mm-hmm still there i think the
house from full house was on sale a
couple years ago
oh it's pulling the house now oh really
yes on netflix fuller house
hey what about the house uh uh we're um
fresh prince of bel-air airbnb airbnb
they just recently just said brentwood
yeah it's in brentwood right now because
they're doing the
30th anniversary they're doing a reunion
episode
they're actually renting it out for i
think
it's not very expensive like less than a
hundred dollars a night it's
renting out airbnb we can do that we can
get it rp uncle field we can do that
yeah it's out of brentwood yeah just
right here
right here fifteen hundred birds flew
into some of the philly's tallest
skyscrapers
in one day last week they couldn't but
this is like two weeks away
why so they think it's because of first
of all uh the weather change
something with the weather and also a
migration period but the fact that they
had one
like one single day 1500 that just
crashed into the walls and died
yeah but also if birds are stupid enough
to hit those windows dude i would see it
all i thought i'd be a crazier
i thought it'd be like some other
crazier type of event like yeah
but i guess it's just yeah migration
patterns
and weather but that would be some sort
of like crazy phenomena
did i see it all the time i worked at a
hotel it was like all glass
in arizona yeah and they were literally
all the time started on nemo damn hit it
and survive
uh one did it lay there for a while and
we were like oh [ __ ] how do we move it
all of a sudden it just got up and then
peaced out
guys i've never seen anything like it
there were birds everywhere they were
all dead
it was that malice that was it they were
they were dead
girls i immediately jumped out of bed
this was a big deal
i just can't stop thinking about it
i'll tell you right now i will not think
about these stupid birds
it won't the last thing i'll [ __ ]
think about
birds are [ __ ] stupid what was that
[ __ ] movie of the happening
yeah a lot of people hated it i loved it
it's kind of it's like
goofy that was a m night shyamalacka
movie
it was supposed to be you know it has
happened before um